Right Ladies and gentlemen,
Bobcat Goldthwait and better known as Bob Bob's here and Barry Crimmins.
Thank you very much for coming.
I really,
really appreciate it.
It's great to be here.
Where are the drugs?
We got a lot of stuff,
but I'm mostly a pot guy,
so if you want that,
we got that.
But we got plenty of alcohol.
I know you enjoy that,
sir.
When I was a kid,
my first started doing stand up,
I,
you would go on stage and you would pull a Budweiser out of your blazer that was
part of your,
you're jazz open where I'd walk out smoking a cigarette and then pull a beer out
and take a big chunk of it as a kind of a health nut.
That was the open,
you know,
uh,
it was,
a very fortuitous,
um,
just amazing situation to be starting out and stand up in 1988 in Boston who was
such an incredible spot to be in.
Just total dumb luck where I decided to do an open mic night.
Dumb luck got me there.
Yeah.
Dumb luck.
Got You there.
But for folks who don't know,
you were one of the reasons why Boston became what it was and you and the,
the community that you sort of established at the Ding Ho was the legendary
community.
When I came along it was already gone.
Right.
When did it,
when did it end?
Around 83 84 something like that.
And then I went to stitches and try to maintain that.
But then,
you know,
I've,
I,
I mainly be became a comedy producer to get stage time and knew other comics
needed state and also new comics needed to be treated like someone when they
walked into a joint,
cause I'd been around the country and been treated like shit,
just stand in line.
You know,
you have 12 hours since you've got an align and you get on for three minutes and
then they tell you you can't come back for three weeks.
And it's like well I fucking hitchhiked here and you know,
just camping out to do comedy and now I can come back in three weeks.
Thanks.
And it's something gruff shit head with a clip board who was nasty.
So anybody that walked in the doing,
I tried to make sure they were treated well and given a fair chance.
And the thoughts that when we put our shows together,
people who feel like there's somebody,
you're going to act like there's somebody and they're going to do a good job.
And I,
you know,
I took it,
the proof is a remarkable amount of great talent that came out with her
phenomenal amount.
I mean,
it's bond.
Oh,
I,
oh,
is uh,
just naming the open Mike Comedians,
all the,
all the greats.
He's still remember Lenny to lose it.
Yeah.
Charlotte Gallo do.
I was like,
I always,
yeah,
Nicole.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
I remember up his arms when he taught what he did,
his act,
he didn't,
you know,
like it was like he's doing his act and um,
the crowd was kind of a really terrible thing where the crowd will be listening.
Well,
yeah,
I doubt it.
But,
so the crowd that,
this really evil thing,
when that Barry's hosting this open,
Mike,
I don't know if you remember this,
and then they start laughing at him instead of with him.
And he thinks he's killing in the crowd's going is very
evil and very data.
So he's having the set of his life not knowing that they're making fun of them.
Barry,
it was upset by this and he's like down on the crane,
walks out on stage.
She goes,
I know what you're doing.
I would just stop if it's not nice.
And
Barry get off this page because it's the first time.
It gets to the point where Barry is,
he varies laying on the stage going,
all right John,
tell your last joke ever at the day,
how was your last job ever?
So yeah,
so there was a problem with those kinds of stresses when they get those lefts,
those guys are going to stay in the business like four extra years just based on
that one night because that one set,
yeah,
there was a set at the comedy store with Joey Diaz went behind the stage.
There was a curtain and the original room at the comedy store and there's this
woman who was on stage who's just,
she's whatever.
She doesn't have the gene,
it's just doesn't exist.
But she kept trying.
She was always there and it was one of those things where she would go on stage
like midnight or something like that and she would mostly clear the room.
Um,
but she's on stage and Julie goes backstage behind the curtain and when she hits
her punchlines,
he would open the curtain up and his pants would be down.
So
they didn't know Joey's 300 pounds at this giant.
God,
it's hilarious.
So every time she hits her punchline,
he opens a curtain and she's smashing it as,
as the set goes on,
she gets more and more confident because she starts,
she starts to Strut a little bit.
Finally an audience gets my humor and she's fucking killing.
I mean,
every car.
And the next time she went on stage,
she bombed and she chastised the audience,
right.
Telling them that this stuff killed blast.
And we were like,
fuck.
She'll never know.
Ever catch on.
Did anyone every time?
I believe so.
As far as I know,
no.
And if you told us you would never believe you anyway,
she'd just put it
yeah.
Folder in the back of her head.
The thing,
you know,
that that same thing that keeps us going.
What is that?
You know,
and there's folks that never
done well and they keep going.
Well that was that open mic night thing where people get the phantom laughs
would hear Phantom Lounge.
I was pretty good.
Well I'm not even to this day,
I,
this is the thing that kills me at this kids,
you know,
they,
they find out about you and they want to and they,
oh thanks for what you did for comedy here.
I'm going to send you my latest set and it's them bombing in front of four
people in the fucking pizza shop.
And they say,
what do you think of this?
I said,
I think whatever money you have used to buy this up and destroy it,
are you fucking crazy?
Just sucks.
And you and you and you and you and you have a mortalized it w you know,
don't put shitty sets on.
You know,
and by the way,
kids,
when you walk on the stage and no one knows who the fuck yards,
how about opening with a joke instead of go,
hi,
how are you feeling?
Like that golden moment when you can fucking take the stage
and get somewhere with them,
go whoa.
Like wow.
How did you think of that opening?
How about saying something funny and that's maybe pertinent to where you are
that shows you on the same planet as the audience.
What?
You're the funny guy.
That's why you're walking on the stage.
Just a suggestion.
Well Boston has a very low tolerance for fucking meandering on steroids.
No.
Yeah,
it was.
You had,
he didn't have a grace period.
As soon as he came out.
I think this is the best place to develop because of that.
Because you had to come out guns blazing and he would learn everything else
afterwards.
But you had to get them and if you lost him,
like very few people would start bombing in Boston.
And recover,
like there was very little recovery.
It's like if you,
if you've got lit on fire moments,
I mean,
you could do,
I would do it for fun just to see like,
let's see,
feel it.
We can get out of today.
Cut Man in the corner.
I think I did that subconsciously,
but it was just shitty planning,
you know,
that's what it turned out to be.
But yeah,
it wasn't like that.
It was going poorly.
And then he really pulled it up.
It doesn't happen.
It never happens.
Not In Boston,
man.
Am I enjoying this interview after,
uh,
you know,
two straight weeks of like,
can we get up and talk about yourself all day?
We were talking,
it's,
you know,
the nature of the movie.
Oh,
I've done it.
I've led us into a fucking moron.
Don't worry about it.
We'll be fine.
Chip Monck I can give you an example.
So you know the movie it's called call me lucky.
Oh,
get them some paper towels,
Jim.
Sorry.
No worries.
So yeah,
a little reminder of my visit Joe fresh beer.
It's what happens.
So,
um,
yeah,
so call me like he really doesn't want to talk about it and he's pouring beer
over duty now we can and we can get to it eventually.
I can tell you give examples of what went horribly wrong.
You know what I mean?
It's like we're doing those satellite things and it's like you're talking to
Tate and tea bag in El Paso
and so he's like,
it says,
you know,
cause it's,
the movie deals with buried talking and dealing with and surviving childhood
rapes,
rapes.
You know,
when he was four and you could tell these guys,
they're like,
well we talking about rape,
but you know,
were never serious.
You know,
was really creepy.
Fucking idiots.
It was a word.
Some people are just not,
they just whatever,
they can't talk and make it funny in the morning.
Yeah.
They just can't navigate anything that's complicated or serious or nuanced or
really sensitive emotionally.
It's just some people just don't have the capacity that they shouldn't.
You know,
Ryan Seacrest cave,
you're doing a fucking interview with Ryan Seacrest
call,
are you like,
yeah.
What's your favorite color light?
Three this must really,
I is perfect for that.
I'm,
I'm just kind of in awe of someone like him with an empire because it,
I mean,
I don't know what he does.
I mean negative
home,
he found a home that secretaries tune into.
It's like a whistle that dogs can hear and he hit.
That
was like a drone.
It never goes too high and it never goes too low.
He never says,
fuck this world.
What are we doing without never.
Yeah.
He's not threatening to old ladies radio show in the law.
Yes.
Radio shows.
Amazing.
Really for all the wrong reasons.
I mean,
he's not a bad guy by the way.
I've met him,
did his old show.
He asked to be
nice to say that they'd be a Commie Pbi.
He's a nice guy.
Yeah.
He has to be.
I'm funny,
I can afford to be an ass,
but he's got that market covered.
That bland white guy always wears a suit market cornered,
you know,
nail it.
It doesn't bother me.
It doesn't cause,
you know,
did God bless American people think like I hate like the American idol and all
that stuff.
I didn't really,
I never really cared about it,
you know,
cause God bless America.
You move.
It was fucking awesome.
Well thanks.
Thanks and ruthless and just ridiculous.
I watched it on a plane and there's one point in time I had a fucking like do
this with my earphones
earphones off to talk to you.
This one hits the planes.
I saw it,
I saw last night,
meaning someone leaning over and there's a baby getting shot with a shotgun.
So crazy fucking movie.
But you,
you know,
you've got a point and then you went for it.
I like to say it's a violent movie about kindness,
you know,
it really is.
I mean that's all that Joel's character wants his people to act.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
And it's not,
you know,
I don't even agree with,
I agree with about 90% of the things that he's mad about.
But you know,
because clearly wouldn't work.
It's not a good plan.
When I came up in Boston,
what I was going to say,
what I was talking about.
You get on stage with the beer bottles,
you will,
you,
you had this thing that you represented when you would go on stage.
This is a guy who stood for something,
you know,
and a lot of people didn't,
and I didn't know we were all just kids and finding your way on the stage first
that I was forced to.
I'm sure.
I mean no need to qualify it,
but it was,
it was,
there was a very distinctive feeling,
very distinct feeling when you got on stage.
Like this was a serious person.
This is a guy who was a standup comedian and a very funny person,
but it was a guy stands for shit.
The weights,
this is,
this is what's right and this is what's wrong and when Shit's wrong,
you pointed out and you know I followed your career through the time you did
that.
It was like a set at the problem I think with Randy credico and who else was on
it with you?
Which one?
There was a,
you guys had did the whole political parties.
Yeah.
Oh,
critical tingle when tango,
was
it just you three?
No,
there were several other people.
Bev Mickens and I'm blanking
because know like,
yeah,
you've done so
I'm going to Nicaragua to do comedy.
I'm like,
who books that?
Boston comedy [inaudible] the Sandinista Gig actually.
Billy Downs involved.
No.
Yeah,
we got paid,
you know,
to me and I think know it was,
it was reflective of the way guys were speaking about you,
uh,
in the documentary that's,
you were an important part of that comedy community because you were,
you know,
I think comedy communities are only as strong as the strongest link.
You know,
you could say they're only as weak as the weakest link,
but not really in comedy because it's always going to be open.
Miker is,
and they essentially,
there's a,
there's a weird thing like you're not a comic until you're getting paid,
but kind of they're all comics.
Yeah.
We all were open mackers and aspiring,
whatever,
you know,
whatever distinction you want to put in the beginning of it.
But the strongest member of the community is really where the community lies.
And that's where,
that's where the standards are set.
And so you were very,
very important guy to me when I was coming up
Gel.
That means a lot.
It means a lot to me.
I wasn't thinking,
I mean,
I,
I mean that,
those slots I didn't really crystallized.
It was just trying to do what was right and I was trying to do what I wanted to
be in the situation that,
you know,
I wanted to provide the situation that I want it to be on myself and,
and I,
and I was immediately rewarded for that with who came in and the blossoming of
all that talent.
It worked.
It was great and we hadn't really nice.
We had a really nice run sometimes,
like I don't want to,
you know,
we've done it enough thing whole reunion is,
it's like going to your little league Rian and well where we're really good
team,
but we didn't even win the fucking championship,
you know?
But,
but it's great seeing all those people now and then and whatever.
But we really,
uh,
you know,
we,
we really did it together.
It was just a matter of just providing this sort of one opportunity.
And then as far I did the same thing I want everybody else to do.
I developed at what I was good at when I was good at was talking about what was
going on.
What was your first time meeting him?
Were you nervous?
Was I never met him.
Did you,
did you see him or did you hear about them?
I got the fuck out of the way.
Maybe
you and I knew what you were doing.
I would like it never ends.
I'm on your show
either,
whether if like,
you know,
and I know I get to tell the truth here,
I know what you were doing and I saw the spark there and then I heard what else
you were doing along.
I'm like,
oh now Joe's found and you know exactly what I'm talking about cause you fucking
do it brother.
You do it.
You found what you're supposed to be talking about.
You found what you're supposed to be illuminating people about and then you find
a way to become true,
tremendous it.
And I couldn't be
happier that I played a little role in providing,
helping to create stage time in a scene somewhere where somebody like you came
out of.
So thanks man.
You did great.
Thank you.
You definitely did.
But that fear you have,
you're talking about never went away.
I would have an HBO special and the phone would be ringing and I go,
that's fucking criminals.
And I know it's always you want,
but you might actually say,
you would like go,
hey,
you made a really good point here.
Why the fuck you pick it up?
Bruce Willis,
he's
just like,
go down the line.
And I go,
okay.
I'd be like back and forth.
Well,
I felt that last night when he came up to me after my set,
I was like,
thank God I didn't know he was in the room.
He came on right when I got off stage of like,
Whoa,
I bridge that bullet.
Every movie I make too.
I'm like,
Oh,
I hope he likes it.
Oh man,
I really liked the new one.
Now,
um,
when did you know,
when did you find out about what we're doing this live on the year.
Did you see the New Yorker piece today?
Uh,
no.
No fucking shit.
Is it a Valentine?
The New Yorker and not that tiny piece.
I'm thinking if you get a little blurb and the New York,
are you doing it anyway?
So I'm pretty good mood.
I just wish I had my kettle drum with me so I could play it down.
Doing Dean Don,
Don,
Don Know Yorker don't they don't done,
he went to kettle drum.
That's nice.
Like Henny Youngman.
Oh okay.
Good evening.
I'm just thinking like those Jamaican guys.
But that's like a dope kettle drums.
Yeah,
that's been done in the dean dome.
Dawn.
That'd be nice surprise for me.
Someone could surprise me with the,
you know,
starting to happen when he made it.
Maybe.
We never know,
depending if we do well in a word season doing [inaudible] saying.
When did you find out about the traumatic history?
When did you find out about the childhood rape,
which was a major part of it.
You didn't reveal it until about an hour into the film.
The idea isn't like a spoiler alert thing or anything.
It was,
I wanted people to and when we will be allowed under the theater at the 30
minute,
cause tonally I give clues that somethings coming.
Uh,
and you know,
he talks about some things so you can tell and other people do.
But I,
I,
uh,
you know,
I get it a little weird if people think that I was trying to manipulate him,
I wanted people to meet him,
know who he was it so they can empathize.
I wouldn't say manipulate.
I would say you set it up beautifully.
Sounds great.
It was,
it was,
it was very compelling,
captivating.
But you know,
knowing Barry and knowing about the story because of,
you were telling me about,
I didn't had no idea.
No one had any idea.
He told me before he went to the judiciary,
a Senate hearing.
Um,
well I told you before I,
yeah.
In public at all.
Yeah.
And,
and yeah,
before you did it or talked about it on stage,
but he said that he found my reaction was,
what
was it like?
He was like,
alright cause I said like,
oh there's a reason you're such a dick.
I was like,
oh I've been betting on this all along cause he's going like everyone's going to
like criminals is an alcoholic.
And it was like he could tell,
I would just use it as coolant,
you know,
turn up missing.
The guys was just like,
you know,
running hot.
I really did hot.
I was always like,
I'm a no man,
you know,
he doesn't have the Werewolf,
he doesn't like his personality doesn't change.
He stops for long periods.
He just,
you know,
so I knew
Twain said when the others drink,
I like to help.
And that's,
you know,
so there was,
so there's this anger and pain and my friend that I knew for all these years and
when he told me,
it wasn't like,
I just was like,
oh I was kind of an awful relief I would say would be your response.
Yeah,
I was,
yeah.
I was like,
Oh,
you know,
inside.
I'm like,
and then I went into panic.
I'm going to go,
well,
what do I do now?
And then I thought,
oh,
maybe I won't talk.
Let them talk.
And that's,
and that's what a point is.
It comes out in the film and people,
I would be telling friends about it and they would be saying to me,
what have you talked to anyone about this?
Yeah.
Fuck,
I thought I was talking to you,
man.
You know,
I guess not.
Oh,
I gotta go pay somebody $200 to be put up pharmaceutical dry ice.
So until I stopped talking about it,
that's your plan,
right?
Well listen,
shit head.
I'm going to keep talking about it and not to you.
Goodbye.
You know?
Thank you for help for helping
me edit my friends list.
This guy,
listen,
you've been living in upstate New York for how long now?
About the last 10 to a no fee for this millennium.
What,
what made you decide to go up there now?
What is the Internet and I can do anything.
I can do what I want.
I,
yeah,
yeah.
And if I have to go work or appear somewhere,
I've got to go to an airport.
So I go to Rochester Ethica or you know Elmira or wherever.
But I get to sit there.
It's so peaceful.
So I hope you come visit me.
Joe loves this really fucking tremendous.
They're far away.
Is it from New York City or from four and a half.
Five hours.
So that's how you do it.
You'd fly in New York and you fly in a flyer or a drive.
I don't mind driving there sometimes cause it's sort of,
you kind of get in game mode and you get out of game mode on the way back.
So I like that.
But my house is like,
I finally have the ideal place to do some acids.
So Ah,
yeah,
the parents are the parents come home,
they're me,
not la.
And then I gave it to get good at.
I said I here fucking terrible.
It's awful.
Goddamn government.
I mean,
you know,
for Christ's say it.
Well you do that.
I think they figured out too many people got smart after that sort of came
through.
Oh,
they certainly did.
I mean the 1970s this sweeping act,
the,
when they made all the psychedelics are illegal.
They made stuff that wasn't even psychoactive,
illegal.
They just tried to make everything illegal.
They just didn't want anybody experimenting with anything that's going to make
another 10 Timothy leary,
my,
my friend Tim Walco.
So about cocaine is how I feel.
It's like,
you know,
I don't like to do it.
I don't like to stay up.
I don't do coke.
I don't like to stay up late and complain about my little league coach.
So,
and I was never a coke guy and you know,
in Boston was bad.
I was in the coke guy.
But I used to say to people,
if you want to get high,
I get some acid.
You know,
and see if we're looking for the dealer at at midnight,
know little drug pocket in my jeans,
pull out another 10 hits if we need them,
you know,
but we don't and you won't
get fucking high,
you know.
And that's the thing,
my only acid experience as well.
It was when I was a total mess and I take drinking and taking other drugs at the
same time.
So then you wake up,
well I didn't wake up,
I had just beat the alcohol and Coke wore off in jail.
In the Watertown jail.
Oh Man,
I'm still high water still true.
Yes.
And I remember,
I remember like this,
I thought it was the wall or I don't know,
I just saw this thing going,
you're going
PPP,
the three stooges or the next cell.
That's what it was like.
I figured it out later on.
It was some dude was snoring,
but I was convinced it was cause you were tripping but,
but,
but it could have went on five minutes or an hour,
I'm not sure.
But I remember looking at this thing on the wall.
Oh,
psychedelic drugs definitely make you interpret sounds in a strange way.
That's why those,
uh,
South American showman and have those songs they sing while you take Iowasca.
Yeah.
The whole idea behind it.
I've never taken Iowasca but I've done DMT.
When you do,
which is the same thing.
It's the,
uh,
the active ingredient.
And when you do it with those,
those songs,
like you see the songs dance like you.
Wow.
It's very,
very bizarre and saying,
have you done that with this hunger?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The,
they're called ECO throws.
These South American equals one one experience.
We tripped several times during the night because it's only like a 15 minute
experience.
So we trip like four or five times during the night to these songs.
But they're,
they're incredible.
And this,
this songs,
you know,
they're,
they're recorded live
is the guy,
he's been sober for 34 years.
I'm listening to this like,
it's a vacation you took.
Oh,
nice.
I keep never going to go to Bora Bora.
Colquitt said to me last year,
I've been sober for 33 years.
I think I'm ready to start dating,
I think was wrong.
Oh,
just this is,
this is the songs.
This is all recorded in the John Goal.
While these people are deep in the trance of the mother,
and this guy will sing,
this is just him starting an often whistling does a bunch of them,
but they're,
they're beautiful.
I listen to them sometimes when I'm driving in my car and I can almost trip,
cause I remember this
variance of being wrong.
Hey,
I'll get you a copy over iTunes.
I don't think it,
I bet.
Isn't
that
wow.
I love that guy.
She's here when these geometric patterns are dancing to that sound.
Very,
very bizarre.
LSD was my other drug of choice of friends and my drug of choice.
But LSD back in the day,
you know,
let's do some more.
I almost have something figured out.
You almost get to hang,
you know,
I got to do with it.
Like let's go in there one more time.
Yeah.
And I also,
and you know what,
I never tell the story,
but I'm thrilled to tell to you,
I was the red Adair of LSD.
You know,
you don't write a dare was he was the guy who jumped,
he'd like parachuted in to put out a oil,
oil Derrick fires.
I don't know who that was.
If you've heard of that expression,
not a dare.
Red Adair was parachuted in to put up.
Yeah,
yeah,
they would.
And he would lead a team and they would go in and they will put out,
yeah,
it look it up,
right it there.
I'm sure you could foil fire.
Yeah,
like oil.
Well at bluff and you go in,
it's like who the fuck is going to go in here and deal with it?
When someone would be bombing out on acid,
I would get the call.
They're bombing out and it's in those days,
in the early,
late,
early seventies if they bomb out then they could end up going to the doctor or
hospital or whatever and then suddenly you there blathering.
They don't,
they'll turn in everybody and it's,
nobody's doing anything.
We just all got some acid.
One person got the acid but they weren't drug dealer.
They were just the obtain or of the acid,
you know,
but the two gave it to me and that person would,
it could end up in fucking Attica or something.
So I would get these calls from people like they're freaking out and they,
I got this reputation for being good at helping people who are freaking out
doing acid and then we're going to go like,
okay,
what'd they do?
They did these.
How many they do?
They split one.
Give me two.
I gotta get in there quick
and I would get in there and then it would be like a hub.
I'm laughing in a while and like I would do stuff like get me a temple orange,
just get me one,
you know,
like I like to eat days.
Wow.
Isn't that.
See it's okay.
We are on a planet that these things grow from trees.
It's an amazing place.
Put on an l,
but what do you like?
Come on,
loosen a little Joni Mitchell.
I see those things.
I know what's freaking you on.
Those hieroglyphics you think are almost words,
but you can't quite read them and you're now you're getting frustrated.
No,
it's just a cool thing.
It's like looking at a beautiful Egyptian crip carbon thing or something.
You,
obviously you can't read Egyptian,
but you kind of get that point they were making.
Don't worry about it.
He'll be out in an hour later.
We're all laughing and the next morning we're at breakfast and it's cool.
But I,
that's when I was in the Red Adair Abella state.
He's freaking out on acid,
like freaking out our mushrooms.
We,
you just trying to control it and you get scared of the experience where it's
taking you.
I think it's probably maybe a little worse.
And plus,
I mean,
you know,
there was shitty acid out there sometimes a little bit and that wasn't that
shitty.
I mean,
uh,
it's hard to make,
right?
You got to get a bunch of stuff.
And then they monitored very still for though is,
you know,
to me it was my favorite.
I,
you know,
if I can never get ahold of,
but I'll do it.
But Bob calls me and then we'll be a lifelong illness.
The enthusiasts,
like I'm doing it all the time.
Great credibility to my,
in this age of drug and McCarthyism,
I'm fucking how many people they ruined just by that day.
I made you look bad.
Oh fuck.
Sorry
to say it wasn't a lot of guys doing it.
Shea in Boston,
you were one of the primary acid enthusiasts.
Well,
but yeah,
but I was wondering,
but I mean like by then it was hard to find,
but I would do,
it was from the 60s it was a big deal.
Right.
So it was around,
I was at the,
in Miami we literally had an oil drum full of yellow sunshine.
Oh my God.
It was unbelievable how much is dead and the oil's however many a drop.
Right?
Yeah.
There was a lot of them.
I mean we just kind of,
it kind of,
someone was in some sort of trouble and he needed somewhere to put it and then
they disappeared.
I just,
we sort of inherited it and it was like,
it's like,
you know,
I don't know why everybody.
And then everybody just left with like baggies full that aren't even bag he's
done.
But just like fill up your pockets last and,
and go,
go home and go.
That was true breakdown.
Does it only lasts for a certain amount of time?
Well,
I had enough play up,
plenty of friends,
Jesus Christ,
you know,
and it was things like grateful dead concerts where they needed a lot of help.
So it was all right.
So you 10 years ago,
he just decided,
fuck it,
I'm going back to where I grew up.
Is that what the deal was?
Basically.
I mean,
you know,
uh,
15 years ago now.
But yeah,
I mean,
I love the country,
you know what I mean?
In really soothes me and,
and,
and I,
and I finally just sort of noticed to cut myself a break.
You know,
I've taken enough of,
uh,
you know,
they haven't been through enough shit and it just soothes me to be there with,
with a dog and it just loved the terrain and it's so Verdun there.
I mean,
I know a little bit out here.
It's so great to come here,
especially to see my friends like you to doing so great and having succeeded.
It's a completely different thing to come to la now than it was when I first
came to La and we were all trying to get our foot in the door.
But it's,
it's really nice.
It's serene and I can,
you know,
and it's a really nice place to sort of rake my self into a pile and,
and my thoughts into a pile and then this distributed to them and,
and uh,
reflect a in,
in,
in in comment,
want to have something to say but you know,
be perfectly fine for being missing for a week or two at a time.
Well this is not,
this is not forced input up there.
No,
no,
that's,
that's the beautiful thing about being anywhere where there's very few people
just less input.
When people come to my house,
like a car,
we'll drive by when they first get there in six hours later,
another car will drive by and go,
I don't know where other spoken traffic's coming from today.
Sorry.
But it's actually two dirt roads to get to his house.
It must be fun.
Go Past.
There's a,
there's a young girl with a giant sow on a chain,
a chain.
There's a woman walking it pig.
It was like it,
it probably weighs 500 pounds.
You know what I'm talking about?
That Jake was killed in a horrible accident.
Car Accident,
Barry.
Yeah.
The Dryer was basically total Jesus Christ.
We have a joke about how Barry can ruin anything.
I saw a pig,
it's dead and moving on.
So when 2000 rolled around,
I guess you just decided to just do it.
Once the Internet started kicking in,
you made a conscious choice to try to go some more.
That's a little bit more peaceful.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And I heard you talk a little bit about,
but have you,
have you thought about doing a podcast?
I mean if you know it just
because,
and I are going to [inaudible] and I are going to do it and he was going to be
called over to the podcast,
which is the upstate and they defeated tall.
Josh moved back.
He just come back.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
I'll speak to you and I'll speak to you.
And the upstate home for is like 193 inches of snow.
Last year I just sat in my house and I worked out my alcoholism till I could get
the door open again.
That's where I,
what is Paul doing these days?
A lot of art people buy as art and um,
and then we're,
you know,
we're trying to get the uh,
the podcast going,
but he's been pretty busy cause he's been swamped with art orders and I'll be
pretty busy after he hit that pig.
It was a performance piece.
Does you go
performance piece?
Well,
yeah,
I mean you could easily do a podcast up there and if you ever do it,
please do let me know and I'd be happy to promote it and I would listen to it
every week.
Thank you man.
And I listened to you all the time and you,
I mean,
you killed,
maybe you just really,
again,
to have even helped like rake the dirt that you grew out of it.
This is terrific.
Thank you very much.
That's an honor.
You certainly did.
You were you,
like I said,
you were the strongest part of that.
You and I have had like some little Twitter conversations back and forth over
the years about the community and what it's like now.
His Boston is so make it a little bit of a resurgence.
I keep hearing that and Rick Jenkins is trying to do something in that Chinese
restaurant.
It's kind of ironic that it all started out with the Ding that goes back.
It's definitely,
there's some sort of connection between comedy and Msg.
You can't deny it,
but back in those days,
the MSG would make you pay the comics.
Ooh.
Uh,
made it the thing.
Oh,
I get it.
Rick doesn't pay.
No,
I don't think he makes enough money to,
and I understand that,
but I don't really advertise.
Right.
Isn't that like part of his fun thing?
I doesn't let people know that this is the sugar going.
Let them figure it out.
Yeah.
If you're invited,
it's okay.
But no,
a great job.
He's been there longer than I,
he,
he's probably the longest running comedy Club in Boston history movie there.
Yeah.
I saw this stuff with,
uh,
with bearing now,
cause you know,
I didn't want to do that.
I didn't want to do that,
that thing in,
in documentaries where they have the triumphant
return,
cause that's always feels very cooked.
But I just wanted to show that Barry was alive and still relevant and that's
why,
and,
and it ended up being great.
It was Bradley Stonecipher,
the DP who suggested it.
And then a really good because of Barry ended up narrating a good portion of the
movie from the stage.
You know,
like when he says,
you know,
we went back,
we went to that basement were while I was raped as a kid,
you know,
that,
um,
that was,
that was not something that I,
that was cooked.
It was something that,
uh,
I was going to film the,
the space where these things happened because I thought that would be powerful
and I didn't want to do reenactments.
Yeah.
Neither do die.
I would have been testifying in front of another committee.
What's the fuck?
Oh my gosh.
So,
uh,
so,
so when we got there next,
ma'am,
Barry and I,
well before we got there,
we had a big argument and he says,
look,
I'm going down there and because I would just kind of wanted him to put it in
perspective,
but I didn't want him to go down the basement and,
and uh,
cause I also was afraid,
I was worried for my friend.
I've seen them go in this shock.
I've seen it.
I saw it coming on when we were even there.
I mean it came on.
Yeah.
I mean,
but even before you got out of the car,
you know,
before he got out of the car.
But I know how to operate in a state of shock.
That's all I did.
The child pornography investigation,
then that's how I,
you know,
they make their own worst enemy.
The child pornography investigation was a huge part of that movie.
And the,
the fact that you,
I mean I think too,
if it was going on today,
I think AOL would've gotten a lot more fucking trouble.
Yeah.
I think it would be a much,
much,
much bigger story.
But it was also,
um,
well let's explain what happened.
So,
so yeah,
so,
so Barry Discloses,
um,
that he was raped as a kid on stage during a benefit for children,
basically what was for the southern poverty law center,
but it,
speaking up about what happened in Los Angeles,
number one was knocking was the after Rodney King and everyone was knocking
these kids,
I'm trying to get rid of this show.
I'm not looking at all.
So then,
um,
and so I,
I at that point I just sort of put my whole life together and I just wanted to
say,
you know,
kids come from somewhere,
man,
these kids do ride that they come from somewhere that they,
these guys come from a place we're up right up the street from their horror
squalid condition or some of the richest people in the fucking world.
And they see it and they don't know what to do and guess,
well,
Gee,
they want some stuff when things about what a surprise.
So I was speaking up for them and it was this long rap.
And then at the end of it I said the w everybody comes from somewhere.
I come,
I came from someone,
then I told my store.
Yeah.
And then about it,
he had,
he had planned on that.
That's how the set was going to go.
Cause Sweeney wanting to close and berries like I don't think you should close.
He insisted on it.
I'm like,
well all right so Barry talk,
see how many cars,
I've never said that to anybody,
but in so many words that night while he was a
good loan,
let's go.
Yeah.
So as a Jack Hammer,
an ambulance,
it's mass ave.
Yeah.
So,
so when Barry's looking for other survivors,
he became aware that AOL was allowing pedophiles to exchange child pornography
openly in their chat rooms.
Not just exchange it,
but back then the more you use,
the more you paid.
So they were profiting.
It wasn't like today you can get online all day long and you're making that
point.
So it was a big deal.
So it's a lot of money,
millions,
millions then playing dumb with me because one night is bothering them and they
just,
well thank you,
you're being a good citizen of the Alo community,
but we have to balance in his Bob notice,
you know our corporate growth along with First Amendment rights.
I was like,
what are you fucking kidding me?
These people are exchanging pictures of children being raped.
There's no first amendment right.
I don't give a fuck about your corporate growth.
Fuck you keep it up.
And then right before they asked me to testify or when I was already invited,
has to testify two days before,
they are well contexts me and says,
you know what?
You like to get together and meet.
And they were,
they were going to come up with the bribe and I went,
you know what,
I,
you know what?
I'm going to see you Tuesday at the hearing or whatever,
Dale.
So what do you think?
I would have loved to have meet with them or here you meet with them just to see
what their plan was.
I wanted to talk to that guy now,
but he wouldn't be in the movie.
The attorney for AOL.
What's he up to now?
I can say it and stick somewhere.
Yeah,
it's busy.
Okay.
Listen,
he's,
he's not an attorney anymore.
Oh,
well maybe stop stops.
He's a running paramount.
So you guys keep talking.
I'm going to the man's room.
So,
yeah.
so Barry,
uh,
after,
after Barry testified,
he wrote an article in the Boston Phoenix that I thought,
and this was in [inaudible] 95 and I thought it read like a frank capra movie.
You know,
this,
you know,
apart,
we should,
I'll fill in more of the holes of the story because Frank Capra,
frank capra,
it's a wonderful life,
Mr. Deeds,
all those kind of,
you know,
so,
so he,
so Barry,
uh,
basically you didn't even pose his kids.
He just signed on his kids and that's all it took.
And he got all this evidence against these guys and he basically embarrassed AOL
on the floor of the Senate.
Um,
but he,
he pretended to be a child to get to lure these child guys.
But it wasn't even that much.
It wasn't even that much.
Um,
you know,
it wasn't really that much of a bait,
it was pretty easy.
Yeah.
Just say,
Hey,
two kids
when we're on and our parents don't cause he played,
uh,
as he,
as if he was a girl and a boy and all,
it just,
just came pouring in.
It wasn't like he was in trapping these guys.
They were just pouring in and he spent,
you know,
almost a year,
and downloading all these things.
He gave it ours.
It's an hundred pounds.
Yeah.
It's not in the movie,
but he,
because he had given the evidence over to the feds.
And the reason it's not in the movie is that there was a rest that were made
directly because of the stuff that Barry and handed over.
But the FEDS,
Warren interested in being in the movie,
I think,
because Barry kind of did their job and you know,
and,
um,
so,
uh,
where is he?
Oh,
so he,
he begged me to make the movie.
No.
So,
no,
so,
so this reads like a frank capra movie and I asked Barry to write a screen play,
but this is right what you just said.
He had lost a hundred pounds and I was like going Barry,
this article you wrote for the Phoenix is tremendous.
I think it's a picture,
you know,
and uh,
can
make money.
Yeah.
By the way,
you have no idea how to write a screenplay.
And so Barry,
what,
what was your motivation like when you,
when you knew that they were trained,
they were trading pornography,
child pornography,
excuse me,
I don't care about it.
They,
you,
you decided the way to catch them or the way to gather evidence on him was to
pose as a child?
No,
what I did,
what I needed a reason to be in the room.
Okay.
If I was in the room as an adult,
right.
They would,
they spacious.
Right.
If I wasn't sending child pornography back to them,
so I needed to be a child.
Right.
So then they're going like,
look at the fund.
You could have.
That's what they're literally doing and approaching me with.
Doug Stanhope wrote a whole book about it,
baiting.
He used to do it all the time,
like back in the old days.
He used to call it baiting and he used to put it,
publish it on his website,
baiting child porn,
people baiting pedophiles.
I got to meet Doug.
I've never met him the best.
I hope they love the fuck out,
dude.
Maybe you could fuck.
Yeah,
I'll fly him in to tell me where you're going to be.
Let's do it.
Okay,
great.
Great.
It's,
it's a crazy thing that when you were doing this,
it's sort of analogous to how people got away with pedophilia and how they got
away with child molesting back in the day because it was something that was
almost,
it was,
it was just to solve taboo.
It's in the favor of the perpetrator.
That's why we have to break silence.
That's why we have to be like kind of specific about differences.
It's like people say to me,
wow,
you admitted you were raped.
I didn't fucking admit anything.
I was raped.
I,
you know,
guilty people rape.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
I didn't admit anything.
I guess like that you admitted you what they hell they robbed your home,
you know,
you wouldn't mind.
You were held up at gunpoint while I had disclosed,
I chose to disclose.
Not everyone sort of has the wherewithal to do that or the makeup to do that.
But fortunately I did.
So I disclosed but I didn't miss anything and they turned the
deep,
dark secret he had no,
I dealt with it when I could.
And I,
and I talked about it when I could in a fashion that I tried to make it as
accessible as possible to other people.
So people would know like,
look at this guy,
this guy is sensible,
this guy's got something to say.
This guy seems to be lucid and now he's saying this but,
but the,
the,
it,
it took a toll on him.
And so it was a hard time for me because you know,
he was Barry and,
and I saw how ill he got and I was making police academy for,
it was really taking away from my time on the south and lost.
He was lost a hundred pounds while you're doing that.
Well,
it also became a vegetarian and stuff done.
So there's a variety of people draw whatever conclusions and there's some stuff
in the movie.
I mean,
I just hooked people up to be in the movie.
I'm going to,
I didn't say,
Hey,
remember to say this or remember I just backed off and I didn't loom while Bob
was making the movie,
I thought it was enough of a task.
So I tried.
The one thing I could do is I just kept saying to people,
it's Bob's,
it,
it's about my life.
It's Bob's movie and Bob's movie about my life is something I'm very,
I,
I put my money on the right,
the right spot on the table,
you know,
so I,
and I knew that coming in,
I knew he would do me right,
but,
but is like,
there's parts in the movie that my daughter has a problem with because the,
the one is the basement because it looks like I,
I asked him to are kind of manipulated.
It went the other way.
The fight was,
he's on,
I'm going down there and you go through a problem,
not around it.
You can film this or not.
I'm going down and your daughter a problem with them because she didn't like me
looking like a,
a manipulative guy and she didn't like the scene with your sister,
be cool again.
And my sister,
I don't tell anybody,
I just said,
Bob's making a movie about my life and,
and then she,
I want,
at one point in the movie she says,
well,
you know,
I knew you were going to interview me,
but I didn't know there'd be cameras here.
It's a fucking movie,
Mary Jo.
But she's my sister and she literally saved my life is very well,
may have saved my life.
It was close because the degree of violence and that's just the physicality of
things and whatever.
So important to the movie because people want to discredit victims of abuse and
to have a witness as much time as we should give those people,
you know?
Yeah.
But I would just,
I'm just wanting to show him that we're iron clad.
Oh yeah.
That's why.
That's why it was key.
I mean,
she did me a big salad,
not just you.
So,
so Barry went into the original big salad is what I'm talking about.
You know,
when she walked in,
if she hadn't,
who knows?
Maybe that day,
maybe if that guy wasn't stuff that might be able to,
because the girl that was involved as well,
the girl that the babies lured you in and brought the guy over and then the girl
was trying to stop your sister from getting away.
I mean,
it was,
her heart was when I was watching that,
my hands were sweating.
It's,
it's just,
uh,
your sister's crying.
It's like,
Whoa,
yeah,
whoa.
It's uh,
and then cut to get evening.
And there's a very bright young comic from upstate New York.
It's like when,
when Barry was in the basement,
you know,
and,
and to me what he says there is very,
you know,
it,
it proves that he's not living in it,
that he's bringing the message back to the tribe,
you know,
very Joseph Campbell kind of stuff.
You know,
that's the,
you know,
the end.
It's a great fourth act.
And so he says,
he says to me,
he goes,
I totally blacked out.
I don't know what I said is any of it thinking about the movie,
which was very sweet.
He goes,
it was any of that usable.
And I said,
I don't know.
I'm playing Yakety sax the whole time you down in that basement India.
He goes,
yeah,
you could animate it and stuff.
So,
but you know,
people get weirded out by that.
But how else,
how about the two guys that genuinely love each other?
We had to make plenty of,
we had to keep making plenty of jokes as I went along through some of the,
yeah,
of course,
one of the jokes that only he can make and then I can get away with a little bit
because,
because I'm Clyde fully licensed Bob to use my jokes.
But in any,
in any case,
you know,
uh,
I'm glad I went into that basement for a few reasons.
Number one was cause other kids go in that basement.
I didn't want to imply that it was imbued with some sort of supernatural power
cause this rapist had been there.
You know what?
It turns out Rapiscan not imbue stonewalls with their evil.
It just something that happened within those stone walls.
And then I went down and said,
hopefully it was a good spirit to say any kid who's ever been in here or any kid
who will ever be in here,
I hope you have fun and you play with your friends and everything's okay and no
one else ever gets hurt here ever.
And that was really important to me.
And the other thing was,
I kind of,
as silly as it sounds,
it's sort of crunchy granolas it sounds in a way,
well,
I mean,
I had,
I thought about that place for so long,
I wasn't gonna walk up to the door and give it the kind of power that I couldn't
walk in there.
I had every right to walk in there.
And,
and so I did.
And in a way I walked in there and I,
and I collected myself as a small child and we all walked back up the stairs and
they did a beautiful thing in the movie where they talk about it.
I'm walking up the stairs and then,
then this u s uh,
I mean this a district county prosecutor from Cuyahoga County in Ohio says
Barry,
you know,
like we've arrested over a thousand people for trading child pornography in,
in Cuyahoga County.
And a lot of what he did is the basis of what's being done nationally about this
heinous crime.
So it's,
you know,
I mean,
it's a fucking beautiful bow on.
It was like a ridiculous package.
And I'm in Cra and
man,
did we name the movie the right thing?
You know,
I'm so fortunate.
What year was this that you were doing this with the,
uh,
AOL 95 95.
So this was the beginning of the Internet.
Yeah.
And,
and like in the movie where the senators so proudly talk about how literate they
are with computers.
Yeah.
I don't know who they're trying to appeal to their,
I suppose to make 'em folks see or something.
Yeah.
It's,
it's just incredible that 20 years ago it was that easy to trade child
pornography that it was just,
they were,
were less about it.
They,
and they actually,
they would attack someone who challenged them rather than like someone coming in
and going like,
Holy Shit,
someone sues what we're doing.
Scatter,
you know,
at least that what happened.
Now at least,
at least they know they're in a little,
there's some sort of danger.
Back then it was like,
well,
this is a natural progression of thing.
And,
and,
and plus I'm just reading these guys and you know,
I,
I will read what my enemy,
right.
So I like,
I studied nambla and what they had to say.
And these fucking people,
if you're not familiar with Nan up,
watch the movie powder,
uh,
it basically puts the entire philosophy of nambla into a film that Disney paid
for that was directed by a convicted child molester annually.
Yeah.
APPS Fuckin lutely.
Well,
I didn't know that.
Oh,
the boy had all the power and he looks like Michael Jackson.
It's like,
so I thought it was about like a magic kit or something [inaudible] or
something,
but it's not a magic kid has this power all the,
yeah.
It's fucking fit.
A,
a missing [inaudible] of the millennium.
Yeah.
It was the movie,
I think Clown House.
And he had caught actually actively abusing children,
a child and that child actor,
he was caught and went to jail with it for it.
And then Disney makes it fucking film with this guy and I wanted to get,
well yeah.
Here was the film made mid nineties to the Internet.
This is Sean Patrick Flannery,
right?
Yeah.
I guess.
Wow.
Yeah.
So fuck that guy.
Fuck him.
I know about him.
I know what it is fucking movies about.
It's the fucking nambla philosophy put into a movie like this kid has a power
over everyone.
It's everything's the kid's choice.
Fuck you.
Everything isn't the kid's choice.
You're allying fucking sack of Shit Creek fucking child rapist that Disney hired
and when you look at Disney and they let that guy direct a movie,
just consider who might behind it.
Be behind the fucking goofy mascot,
their theme park.
Thank you.
Wow,
that is crazy.
This is the guy.
That's right.
Victor Salva look at that.
Must have ran fucking relentless sec.
Yeah.
I actually friends with a number of what?
I didn't know who got them in the right corner.
A picture,
but I like American film director,
best known for directing films,
powder and jeepers creepers.
Jeepers creepers.
That was a horror movie.
That was a good movie.
Fuck.
But I'm attracted to controversy.
Were being a convicted.
Where is he now?
I don't know,
but he better not be too close to him.
How is that?
He's directing the full house reunion,
really for four house.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
There you go.
Hey Victor.
A little press for you today,
Vic Victor Back.
You fucking NAM bluff fucking proponent.
Fuck you.
Piece of shit.
Fuck Disney.
Yeah,
to.
Yeah.
So when he directed them,
I get mad when I see 37 he was only 37 convicted sex offender.
Wow.
What else did he direct you directed children and did harm.
Look at that.
Hold on.
Oh look at that vice piece.
He loves convicting.
Loves terrorizing.
Semi naked youths.
What this is from 2012 what is this?
Oh my God,
Jesus Larian.
Oh my God.
Did people think of a pet rest or sexually DV to film director?
They are likely to imagine Roland plants giving sex with a 13 year old or what
are y'all and marrying it up to done.
But those stories were a bit tired and cliched now.
So for those of you with a thirst for horrible stories about film and abusing
their power,
we present mid budget journeymen director of Victor Sal journeymen.
He's on a boxer.
You know,
what does that mean?
Mid Budget journeymen.
What a weird,
distinct,
shy.
Now was just a riot in 1989 salvo was jailed for last minute journeyman.
No bobcat.
Glad.
Thanks.
Clapton should sue these guys.
Um,
I have my own house.
He so he was jailed after Melissa.
Don't real star.
You know what don't so don't rent his smoke.
We don't pay for his next defense.
And by the way,
the Gary Glitter's shit,
they play in every and every ballpark that that's his fucking defense one.
Duh,
Duh Duh.
And I won't finish it.
But Hey,
you know that song he makes money on that.
Every time a ball games going on the plots,
victims of clown house or three prepubescent brothers led by the deputy.
Have you taught Sam Rockwell who spent their time running sterically around the
enormous sub sobriety alley as three pre pubescent kids in that film too?
What funny.
What a piece of shit.
I came and look at the smell.
It's just kinda not in jail.
I thought when you go to jail,
you go to jail for a long time.
Now you'd be surprised.
Well that's,
I'm surprised right now because he came out and Disney and let a minute,
God Damn Millennium Make a God damn movie that was the Nam Bluff movie of,
it's like,
you know,
the nambla film festival outside of God knows what they would show.
So what does nambla his philosophy?
That's the,
basically it's the kid's choice.
That's their run.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's the kids.
Oh,
my kid lead the kids make all the decisions.
You know,
I used to think that an Ambo was something that they joked around about,
like I thought it was a real thing.
No,
I mean,
we see here Howard stern talk about it and [inaudible] real and,
and it's not a joke.
So look at,
the thing is,
it's like the Communist Party nowadays,
you go to a meeting,
you know,
it's like 80%,
uh,
FBI agents.
So enjoy yourself.
Namel guys remember the hilarious thing when they had a nambla meeting at the
San Francisco Library and I film crew came in and everybody walked out,
like crouching there.
They're all like walking like you're Groucho Marx.
No,
they wouldn't stand up.
Uh,
you know,
I bet we could find it.
Nambla and VA Nambla San Francisco Library.
It's,
it's hilarious.
I just,
I thought for sure if something like that happens,
you go to jail for a hundred years.
I mean,
I don't understand how this guy could have been out at four.
yeah,
that means that 37 so if he was convicted and then he was out at 37,
he couldn't possibly have done more than,
you know,
17,
19 years.
Right.
If he was 18 he didn't,
he didn't do anything close to the,
and then we did a little bit,
he did a little bit.
And then when they made the movie though,
here's the thing,
if he wasn't directing that film at 17,
18,
you know,
I mean,
he,
he only did it a bit of time.
Mother Fucker,
you know the movie that Green Lit,
that's the only thing that's weird.
They knew his past and then the green that,
that movie and he was released on parole and 90 to 15 months into his sentence
will,
yeah,
he laid low for a while,
planning his next move.
What the fuck does that mean?
I don't know.
Oh my God,
let me man,
he the registered sex offender who had recently been drove and then,
cause I like,
I was hired to make a film for Disney.
So it was Disney film pillar was a straight potter,
a freakishly intelligent albino boy with telepathic and telekinetic powers.
The film was marketed as a modern day female tail,
which started such as household names is Jeff Goldbloom and was at the time to
create,
to be asleep or hit after across $30 million worldwide out stripping.
It's modest.
$10 million budget.
Yeah.
All I remembered was that,
oh my God,
you touched me and I've had better.
So what does that say?
Um,
give Jeff Golban comes across powder and empty cafeteria and says to him,
you touched me and I've had better sex than I've had in 10 years.
I want to be a friend that's not creepy.
And,
and,
and it,
this thing get good reviews.
You touched me and I had better sex.
Yeah,
I have.
Man,
we hit.
That's why I love,
I was looking forward to doing this cause I know we would hit some stripe,
you know,
some vein that you would completely dig,
man and you and you get it.
See,
this is my work.
This is what I'm fine.
Oh fuck yeah.
Takes powders hand as his hair supposedly due to an electric current begins to
stand on the end.
So the idea is that the polling and the power of this child makes his hair stand
out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Then Goldson tenant movie and it's a rest is powders face and bald head for
around 20 seconds.
What the fuck is wrong with Jeff Goldblum?
I don't know.
Jeff.
What is the wrong with you?
The fuck.
I don't care.
I don't need to meet movie stars.
Fucking,
you know,
come on.
Gee,
I'm glad you're on the fucking rent.com horror ads now apartment let it's
falling apart.
Well not good luck to you both.
What the fuck?
He was really good and Jurassic Park.
I didn't see that.
I missed that.
Can you imagine?
I didn't have to see that.
He said he really liked Coney lucky duty.
Not really.
No,
you're kidding.
Kidding,
kidding.
Totally kidding.
I know that.
Sorry.
I meant,
I mean,
you know,
maybe he wasn't thinking that much.
Maybe the movie was made incrementally and whatever.
So I'll give him a break.
But Disney should have fucking done Disney.
It's whole business is based on kids,
right?
So this is what the big kid studio,
the fucking theme park people,
they put this piece of shit out and it's still sort of like honored is this Po a
critically acclaimed thing and I,
I'm know guy who can put critics,
figure out shit that I'm not smart enough or I don't care enough to figure out.
They can follow up on Garcetti.
And also,
I don't know what the fuck they're talking about,
but this movie,
I know the message better than anybody.
I know what it's about and I know who they're appealing to and they're in there.
They're putting their fucking horseshit in our face and asking us to like,
well,
you know what?
I don't like it.
Disney,
I don't like itself.
I'll go fuck yourself.
I vaguely recollect that this was an issue that someone had brought up to me
before,
but I never investigated it.
Or maybe it was in conversation at the comedy store or something like that and I
never looked into it,
but God damn it.
This is fucking crazy.
There's,
there's fucking jelly in this beer.
What do you mean what's blackberry?
This is going to done a drink.
It fucking Knott's Berry Park.
Can I see what it says?
What is it?
It's really sweet.
It tasted okay.
All right.
Moving on.
These new wave.
It was a really good,
oh,
I got to try in a way,
but it was great.
It's from New Mexico local beer.
All right.
Um,
thank you man.
That's a great thing about doing your show and I've listened to you go off on
these rips for so long.
I got to watch it.
No o'clock in the morning because my don Gavin,
but I got to watch it.
No o'clock shit.
Big Guy.
Yeah.
I gotta Watch.
I gotta watch it.
No o'clock in the morning because I'm on a dish in a,
in a and it uses up too much bandwidth to keep watching.
But if I'm up at nine o'clock in the morning,
I'm,
I'm checking out what you've been doing and you fucking kill me man.
And it's great.
And that's why I was so,
I mean I didn't,
I didn't approach it.
One,
I don't think I might have approached a couple of,
like a very few people I approached to,
can we come on and do your thing?
Do your show.
You're one of the only ones,
man.
And then I'm so glad send you in the last one.
We're doing it.
This is it.
I'm done.
Thank you very much.
It's an honor for me.
I knew I could trust you for me arriving as test pattern boy at the end of
fucking a hundred interviews like,
well let's go back and now what you'd like to call it,
a rape Barry deal as that.
What good is it a sexual assault or rape?
Can we go,
I'm going to go ahead and use that word.
Great,
but it's not all right.
One thing that really sort of kind of defines you and how,
how,
how you approach things.
Very good beer.
It's very good,
right?
Yes.
The waiver,
um,
that you,
you,
you said that if that guy was alive that you would want to show him that he
didn't,
he didn't strike you.
That's right.
I,
you know,
I would show him that my personal revenge would be to behave decently towards
him and he'd been advocate for him to be in a situation confined in,
segregated from any possibility of being near children where he was treated in a
humane fashion.
And if,
and if he weren't,
I would tell him,
you could tell me and I would do something about it because I did not,
I became a human rights activist and not a rapist,
not a,
not,
not a human rights defender.
And so you didn't win you,
the light that was extinguished in new was never extinguished in me.
It's survived.
And I'm so fortunate that it did.
I would have probably said that and then killed them for sure.
Oh,
I stopped spiders.
I'm not a big fan of poisonous things.
Yeah.
Well,
I understand,
I understand well that I didn't experience what you experienced and you have
obviously your,
your anything wouldn't be consumed by the consumer.
You are very strong person to,
to go that path and to go that route and that's indicative of who you,
who you became.
And that's one of the reasons I think ironically like why you became such a
strong leader in this powerful person as because you overcame something
unfucking bearably traumatic very early in your life and you developed this
intense sense of right and wrong.
I think this is a bit of a great time to tell people they should follow me on
Twitter at Cremins CSI mmis.
Let's see the record.
We can send forth followers right now at this moment at Cremins.
I was,
when he was talking about me,
Barry.
Oh
I see is the moment.
This has been the weirdest,
hardest movie I can the Mammo big movie cause big foot.
It's scary and it was fun.
Oh,
I got to hear you guys talk.
I got to show a picture that I think he's going to dig.
Oh,
is it the lizard guy that lives here?
Hey,
hello.
All of Joe Rogan's followers.
All you crazy.
God Damn.
Uh,
what,
what would you describe your politics?
Let's try not to.
Okay,
good.
I think it's,
I'm trying not to define
my politics are wait for the aliens to land my politics.
I like my politics are never trust anyone who wants to be in charge.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
And nobody wants to be presidents.
Shouldn't be president.
I was fucked.
I have a,
I have an idea that people,
it should be like jury duty and that she can be absolutely.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And then,
you know,
hey,
I'm going to go try and do us proud for a week.
I mean,
I like,
I ran the Ding Ho I did that shit.
I could have parlayed that into something,
but I just knew we needed something.
I didn't want to be fucking and charge.
Fuck that.
I want to do my shit.
I think they have to approve of it by height.
Yeah.
How did the Dang,
well I'm out.
Did,
how did,
how did the thing wind up closing?
Lee lost the,
uh,
the tax money in a Marshawn game for real.
I sold out four shows on Saturday.
I went over to pick up my notebook.
I'm Monday,
there's fucking plywood on the door.
And the ultimate thing home not here cause it,
the joke is,
you know,
I used to call the club,
I'd be out on the road and I would call in on Saturday and had to see it and
just got old guy.
Henry is like an 82 year old Chinese guy who took the takeout or it's on the
phone.
I would call up and I would say,
Hey Henry,
it's Barry Barry not here to hang out.
And he got to get,
and this is back in the day,
you got to get another $2 and 85 cents and change.
Couldn't,
couldn't,
couldn't go Henry.
You know,
I want to order,
Shun Lee on the phone,
you know,
like I would have to figure some way to break through his belly and not here.
So it turned into my friend,
the late great John Brown.
Uh,
you know,
the man who wants the man who won the man.
How you fuck the man who wants puked in a wishing well?
Um,
the Patterson Kremlin for it's berry one with you.
Just it.
Okay.
How about yours?
I was watching the movie editing and I was like,
holy crap.
Well this is a lot of bigfoot sightings in upstate New York.
Well that's my thing.
I just do movies about it.
Harry mysterious man that
I was awesome point.
But it doesn't matter.
It's because Bob had to mark,
you were talking about calling up the Ding Ho and then
came to dinner.
Hung out here.
I don't remember the rest of it.
It was
still,
it wasn't enough of a prompt til it's gone.
I have a compartmentalized memory.
I've had a lot and plus I've had a lot of concussions because I played a little
ball and my day.
Oh Mac in the day when spearing was legal.
Yeah.
And widely practiced.
The Gallup man.
Did you enjoy France?
Alameda's a documentary or friend?
Great job fan was a big help.
And our movie,
He gave us a footage that wasn't used in that,
so that was a big help.
It was the first real chance for me to go on record about a lot of stuff and
then us.
And then some of that was stuff Bob ended up using it in our film.
So yeah,
I enjoyed it a lot.
You are in this,
uh,
this is positioned now with this film coming out to help a lot of people.
I think this,
this film is not just going to,
you know,
tell your story and,
and,
you know,
open up a lot of people's eyes as to I hope so.
Oh,
the AOL situation on it.
But I think a lot of people,
you know,
you're such a powerful guy that I'm hearing from them,
Joe,
I'm sure you are.
And,
and,
you know,
and they,
they know how to find me or they will find me and I'll do what I can.
Um,
some I give everybody as much of a chance as I can.
there's a line of what sold
to abuse survivors and I think it's horse shit.
And that's basically they get quote unquote empowered,
and I hate that word because it takes the strength out of the word power.
What's,
what sounds you like more like power power or empowered empowers like sandy
making a wear Birkenstocks or something.
So I'm not that big on mpowered,
but they like I did,
uh,
my friends Sam seed,
there's a podcast a couple of weeks back and,
and he said,
I don't want to give away with the movies.
I said,
listen man,
it's not that kind of movie.
And it hinges largely on the fact that I survived raped as a child.
Well I heard from several people said,
you know,
you really should have had a trigger warning on there.
And it's like,
what the fuck do you shake?
I was doing,
what the fuck do you think I was doing when I said it hinges largely I was
warning you that what it was about right there.
But someone has empowered you to,
to have a way to take issue with me because I'm not completely basing,
I like the whole world isn't based around me.
Even though I got raped when I was four years old,
everybody shouldn't be thinking in terms of that all the time because they'd
been through their own shit and they're dealing with their own shit and they're
trying to survive.
So if I can make them more sensitive to this issue,
if I can show them that it matters to them,
is that they deal with other people who have been through this kind of trauma
and we want to reduce it as much as absolutely possible.
That's good.
But after that,
if I'm going to find a way to set up a situation where I'm always the injured
party and that prove again and again that I'm persecuted and no one's thinking
in terms of me,
then I'm never going to get fucking healed.
I'm never going to get fucking healed.
So one I did was I went out and I tried to help other people.
When I help other people,
I realize how far along I've come and I realized there's really something in it
for me to do that.
And it's not like I'm this altruistic guy.
It's like I'm saving my own life.
And you know like that AOL investigation that took such courage to do it.
No.
What would have taken courage was turning my back on those kids and walking away
going like,
Ooh,
I don't want to know what's going on in there.
I,
how would I live with that guy?
How would I live with myself then?
But they,
you know,
like I is nice.
Everyone said,
Oh gee,
that what he went through when he was doing that investigation.
What about the kids in the fucking pictures?
That's what I want everyone to know about.
Thanks for caring about me,
but it's the kids in the pictures I give a shit about.
It's the kids that are suffering right now somewhere within the sound of my
voice.
Someone you know,
I mean in this broadcast like where this is on someone in the next apartment or
wherever some kid is going through this shit,
have the courage to know about it.
That's all I asked.
You have the courage to know about it and save the contemporary children so you
don't have to deal with a much a fucking maniac.
Abuse survivors went up.
That's all.
And if anybody can diffuse the turn arounds Cape guys coming in now,
if anybody can diffuse the term trigger warning,
you're the fucking guy.
Well thanks Jesus.
God Damn Christ stop.
We're going to,
we're going to develop a nation of permanent children.
Like if anybody can tell their story and doesn't need a fucking trigger warning,
it's you and this,
this idea.
I don't,
I don't need trigger warnings.
If you're going to show me something,
show me something I,
and if I don't want to see it,
let me know what it is before you show me a little,
tell me what the,
the,
we all knew that the documentary was about no need a goddamn trigger.
This fucking term is disgusting.
It's disgusting term does damage.
It just sets people up to sit,
stay in the pit,
you know,
to wallow.
It's empowering them to wallow like,
well I've got hurting again cause the whole set,
it's like [inaudible] shit man.
But I'm telling you what,
I know you're in a pit of your own shit.
I know you're used to the temperature and the smell of it doesn't mean you're
used to that.
And it doesn't bother you that much any more.
But when you stand up and they fucking hose you off and then you go in the house
and take a real shower and put on some clean clothes,
you're not going to believe how much better you feel.
So stop letting other people tell you that you have to expect the world to do
the impossible.
And that's be there like telepathic about what the fuck you been through.
Get to the point where you can stand up and tell them the story yourself when
it's appropriate and don't put up with anybody who was truly being insensitive
or snickering about any of this shit.
Fuck people who tell me,
people walk up to me all the time and tell me like,
well,
you know liquid thing is those guys get arrested.
You know I and booboo took a,
it's like you're endorsing rape to me.
You're fucking endorsing Rick to me,
motherfucker.
I don't want anyone raped ever.
Not even rapist.
Rape is illegal.
How about making jails lawful places?
How about that for an idea?
How about from someone going to jail and realizing the law protects me sometime
I'm not going to be raped.
I'm not going to be managed here.
I'm going to,
and maybe Dale will start thinking about getting reformed.
But Jesus Christ,
don't joke to me about rec.
Don't tell me you want them all killed and sweep them under that rug because I
was born without blood on my hands.
I don't want to fucking blood on my hands now man.
So don't guess the stupid ass fucking lightweight things and presume I'm going
to sign off on them cause I don't I ever want anyone else ever raped.
And if it happens,
even if it's of a rapist,
I'm opposed to it and I don't want them fucking kill either.
Now they don't want them to live with what they did.
Now this is a difficult,
this is difficult thought and is it a difficult subject?
But did you,
after this is all said and done,
are horrendous moment in your life,
many moments in your life,
did you try to figure out what would create a person like the guy who did that
to you?
Did you try it?
I did.
How much time?
Yeah.
I can tell you what created him.
He was taken out of an abusive home.
He was put into foster care and abused many more times and he was gone and he
was gone and he was good and he was succumbed by the agony I was put through by
him.
I survived.
Somehow I made it so call me lucky.
I'm not,
I didn't become him.
I didn't become what I resisted.
I didn't,
I didn't pass along the poison.
Maybe I didn't some ways when I was difficult or whatever,
but mostly I didn't.
Mostly when I'm mad,
I'm mad because it's like Hendrix,
a cry of love.
It's a cry of love that I make.
It's a cry of love.
My Act has been a cry of love.
It's like I don't want the innocent hurt anymore.
I don't want people victimized because of greed and cower to some bullshit,
you know?
I don't want that and so I do what I can to stand up to it.
Did,
were there moments where you wanted to talk to him?
What do you want to talk to him?
I would love to talk to him to show him that I been didn't become a monster like
he was.
I W I would have.
I would have almost become an advocate for him in the sense that like,
well mate,
let me know if they're mistreating you in here,
but he died in prison.
No one claimed his body and I don't know where his grave is.
If I knew her as grave as I go,
put fucking flowers on it.
Not for him.
For me,
the idea that someone could do that after someone did that,
to them scenes,
insanely counterintuitive.
It's like if someone is the only thing that saves you but really saves you,
really is redemptive in really saves you to me,
how well this,
one of the things that you covered in the film that I thought was really a very
powerful moment where you talked about this thing that you didn't become him,
that you may be if your sister didn't come down there and Kevin Dead,
you could have been dead.
It was close,
man.
It was close.
But do you also that you could have been one of them?
You could have been someone who that would have Peterson death.
Yeah.
How I'd rather be a victim of thousand times in the perpetrator wants and that's
not any bullshit.
You contemplate the mechanism.
Did you try it?
Have you tried to understand the mechanism that turns an abused person into an
abuser?
What?
What is the,
I don't,
I don't think I'm as nuts and bolts is zero because I listened to you and I know
how much,
I mean like how,
what detail you go into so I understand how how and what you're asking,
but I can't be,
there's enough of me that's been through enough that I can't be quite as
thorough as you're asking me to be to answer that.
I get as close as I can and I understand what happened,
but then after that point I,
I can't,
I'm not one of them and I can't go far enough to say,
well then of course if you get past this point right here,
then obviously this is that.
I can't do that.
It's that that is what is too much for me.
I just,
you know,
one of the reasons I was interested in making the movie was when,
when buried,
you know,
told me that the guy had died in prison.
I said,
how'd that make you feel?
And he,
he said,
it made me sad.
And I said,
because you didn't get any closure,
you know,
you didn't get to confront him.
And he said,
no,
he died alone.
And,
um,
I was really blown away by that and I thought
I should really make a movie about it.
No,
I thought,
well,
this is like,
you know,
this is Jesus stuff,
and that's what this is.
And so,
so,
you know,
that was what that really did motivate me to make the movie,
you know.
And so the movie was going to be a narrative with someone else playing Barry.
And I thought about that for years.
He tried to establish a script.
I tried and it wasn't till,
you know,
Robin Williams was my pal and he suggested I make it as a dock.
This was just February,
2014.
And,
uh,
I said,
I don't have any money.
He says,
I'll give you some money.
You can start it.
Cause he was a fan of berries and he knew Barry's story.
So that's really how the movie came together.
It came together really fast.
I didn't realize,
uh,
how long it takes to make a doc.
You know,
cause when I was at Sundance,
other directors are going,
yeah,
we started seven years ago.
It's seriously,
I started four years ago and I was like,
I started February and they didn't go,
hey,
all right.
They're like,
hmm.
Okay.
Well good luck with that Bob.
Scratch.
Okay.
How difficult was it to even attempt to tell the story for you as a person who
loves this guy and as we know?
No,
he's out of the room right now.
He's so,
it was so instrumental.
He was such a,
he was the foundation of that whole community,
which I think and how important to you and me
and,
and help mold me,
you know,
as it,
cause I met him when I was 16.
Right.
So it's,
you know,
making it a movie that's not a work of fiction with someone you love that you
want them to like when it's done and you want people to like the movie and him
for the same reason you like him.
It was hard.
It was,
it wasn't,
you know,
like people will talk about making a move in,
let's say that was hard no matter what.
I never think,
you know.
But,
but seeing that this is real people,
I don't want to embarrass anyone.
I don't want to,
no,
I don't want it.
No,
I know.
Yeah.
I had no idea.
I was thinking about how hard I made your work
cause it's like,
yeah,
there's footage,
you know,
what the fuck am I going to do it like that.
Did you,
before this film came out,
was there a time where you were trying to figure out how to tell your story?
No.
I mean I felt like I had told it a lot and I felt like the trail was there and
people could find it.
That this is like the dream that it gets told this way.
But I didn't expect it.
I didn't presume it.
And I was completely honored and flattered that it was done and then it was done
so well.
Um,
but you know what I mean?
Like,
part of me doesn't give a fuck about my story.
I mean,
I just,
like,
I,
I've learned as I've grown up,
I've learned not to take life personally.
You know,
I just,
I'm just part of it.
And so unexpected to stop for me and do,
but it has in this sense,
because Bob stopped it,
got the footage and sequenced it and put it together and thought he's brilliant
ways to approach it and then made this beautiful picture.
I mean,
really I should say it wasn't about me.
If I'm worried about where I'm going,
I mean,
I would,
I would be out crusading to get people to watch this.
It just seems a modest at this point,
you know,
because it's about me.
He made such a tremendous move.
I mean like,
you know,
there's a lot of folks,
I mean Jeff's drank of the course,
but our producer,
your people that you put together,
you know,
uh,
Bradley Stonecipher who I got to see you while I'm in town,
when always always see around.
I don't know.
Yeah,
we should figure that out.
How do you follow this?
Uh,
well we're going to do an a sequel.
I'm going to,
yeah,
call me greedy.
Um,
I'm going to,
you know,
I got a book coming in and um,
uh,
talk about a lot of essays and,
and,
and then a lot of quips.
It's sort of dedicated to generation text.
You know,
the people there like I am so,
I mean,
I'm trying to hang in there,
but it's like a read this shit on Pdt.
G O t r s h.
U half hour later I'm going to like
pudding on other shoe.
What the fuck?
And you've got time to tell me you're putting on your other shoe,
but you've got to,
what years in such a hurry,
you've got to abbreviate it.
So I can't figure out what the fuck you say.
So,
and then I have to be calm enough to try to convey this.
Okay.
Kids?
Yes.
M H is my least favorite one is shake my head.
Oh
yeah,
no,
I and the whole and the whole Emoji thing.
I'm a grown man.
It's like,
come on,
I make smiley faces.
I'm so sorry.
I never did.
I needed to get him here to,
why are they all send them to me?
The whole customer.
I sent one to my friend Paul and he's like,
did you fucking send me a smiley face?
I actually,
I actually texted enough women that I,
I put smiley face emoticon on it.
I don't have any emojis,
but I do look the dot.
Dot.
Smiling.
I,
every time I upgrade my phone,
they put like a million more of these things on there and then I hit it by
mistake.
I'm trying to,
I sent me a Christmas tree that's puking.
I don't know.
I don't know if he's happy or mad drunk.
Christmas tree.
My low,
low,
low.
Like we're regressing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
With hieroglyphs to 100% and then I got a deer with an Arrow pointing at it and
said,
what the fuck does that mean?
Very depressed guys wearing skins.
Know Suicidal Emoji.
It's like how are they?
Are they are?
They are.
So many people will communicate with God and we need the ones we need.
You know the fart pile of dog shit.
That's another one,
right Joe,
that he can to do my Hercules
thing.
I,
you can have people it.
What's your Omegas stores told me they started fall ball.
Die.
Who has the full now I ask you Joe Rogan.
What is that?
That's mine.
That's my old Hercules movie bitch.
Oh,
is it like,
yeah,
but everybody,
no one.
Ah,
they all do it now.
But now is that at first I asked Gil.
Yeah,
I don't,
that's I'm bombing.
It's more like food,
movies stuff.
Oh no,
that was later.
Oh,
it was late.
I mean pre that was Hercules movies.
I told me that stuff on boulder.
At least it fool now.
Testicle.
Lee's.
Yeah,
I was get you go.
Sooner or later,
my friend,
you will come around and you know,
I understand this is not a bottling joke.
Well on audio,
vast majority of our listeners are just that.
Listeners should I maybe like less than 10% probably watch this.
Perfect.
It's better.
I love shit that doesn't work.
When you're,
when you're under upstate,
when you're,
when you're like you go out and eat too.
Is that four beers now for three is good for us tonight.
When you're in upstate and you,
you go out and mentally you're doing these,
uh,
these gigs,
are you,
are you performing on a regular basis?
Like,
no.
No,
but I will be,
I mean that a regular basis is something because that was a part of the film.
Someone was saying like,
I don't know how it makes money.
Like someone was asking.
Yeah,
I'm about to,
I'm about to have a great new speakers bureau called Keppler speakers in New
York.
If you want me to come talk to you,
I will for upbeat and then going out and doing a bunch of shows and getting
ready.
And I would like to,
you know,
I think there might be like kind of avail tick Tory,
uh,
performance.
Uh,
and then I'm Ma might be kind of done,
you know,
maybe just find a little spot lady sell down the country and uh,
relax.
Do you have a desire to do standup again or stand up?
No,
I'm happy to just stay.
I did it last night at the it,
the belly room of the comedy started this fun and they were,
they're like,
wow,
you're allowed to do that.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
you are.
You know,
so it was cool.
And I love doing standup and I love comics.
I mean,
I fucking love comics.
They're my brothers and sisters and,
and,
and you know what?
I put a lot on the line for them and they put a lot on the line for me.
And sometimes people,
like a lot of people coming through and you're like,
I know I don't do what you do.
And I'm so it's like,
no,
I'm supposed to do what I'm supposed to do.
And that's what I was saying to you before you figured out what you're supposed
to do and you're so tremendous edit.
It makes my,
the kettle drums in my heart goes,
Dun Dun,
Dun Dun Dun Dun,
Joe Rogan,
La La Don,
Don,
blah blah.
And I see his movie bobcat.
Goldthwait don't do an dean,
don't Don Don,
Don,
Don.
It's white.
You fuckers got a little few bucks by me,
a kettle drum.
Okay,
we'll get you kettle drum.
Won't have one shipped upstate New York to take you on a fucking back of a 500
pound pig town.
So my point is like,
are you going to,
you're going to tour or mean?
Yeah.
And I will tell you and you will pass it along.
People.
Is there a website that people could find out?
[inaudible] dot com just got completely renovated by my friends at slab media.
Jamon Fatina Catherine Infantino in Boston.
Just today.
We just launched the,
the cleaned up modern version of the website cause I had to like avoid burning
website before this and it has a calendar where people look at that they will
succeed.
Pitch Dun Dun Dun.
So den distinguished,
don't,
that's right.
That's right.
Okay.
So there's an appearance appearances thing and account look at it.
So modern Facebook,
Twitter,
the whole deal.
Instagram,
you've got an Instagram.
I don't use it much but I,
Twitter is kind of perfect for me cause I'm pithy joke guy.
Right,
right,
right.
They played right into it for once it came into my wheel house.
Steven Wright would have been the awesome Mitch Hedberg,
Mitch Hedberg and Steven.
Steven did when he,
when,
when he was using Twitter a lot.
He,
he wrote a book.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was,
he was riding a bike.
What?
I've read a book or on Twitter,
funny for 140 characters at a time.
I imagine getting to know him for all these years.
I mean,
he's like,
one of my dear says,
Eh,
any,
we don't see each other that often when we do.
It's just like talk about just picking right up from where you were the last
time.
And he came up and saw me out of nowhere.
That's why he knew in the movie,
we know when he says in the movie it's like throw had a computer.
Uh,
he,
cause he was there [inaudible] he drove out to see me from Massachusetts just
cause he kind of went on to get some context and then,
and you know,
Stephen,
he's so honest and he's,
Oh,
I'm so glad now I in my head,
I know where you,
you know,
it's just so great.
You know.
So he's back in Boston.
Steven Wright is,
well,
he lives there,
but you know,
I mean he goes out and does,
you know,
as many dates as he wants to live in Massachusetts.
I'm not sure what,
hey look,
he lives kind of on one.
You know,
I,
I don't want to say exactly where he lives.
It's up near the debt for if you went to one of the,
cause he pissed off the Juggalos.
No,
see I keep hearing about the Jones.
I did the gathering.
How was it horrible as you'd imagine.
Yeah,
I would imagine it would be it the same.
It was in the same,
there's no security,
there's no lights,
there's no just people selling bath salts and fighting and,
and there's a video of a girl just pulling down her pants and a bunch of guys
just fucking hair at the,
I've seen that one.
Well it's probably just one video of many.
The Tila Tequila footage where they ran out of Phaco to throw at her,
cause they,
they've sprayed Taylor with Phaco Cola.
So they,
they just knocked over the outhouses and just started throwing shit at it.
Yeah.
I stress human because like if you and I were walking down the street and you
picked up some dog poo and hit me with it,
I'd be mad.
But later on we'd be pals.
We laugh it off.
I got,
what the fuck you,
we were dog
shit.
But you know,
if it was like Hobo Duke,
that'd be it.
That'd be a deal breaker.
We wouldn't be pails anymore.
Oh Shit.
Oh whoa dude.
So whole new bad politics tonight with Hitler's Judaism.
So I had let my opening act was up,
check the clown and he's driving me around the grounds in a golf cart and people
are in the jugglers.
I getting out of the way like who are the millionaires?
You know,
so this Juggalos runs up,
runs alongside the golf cart and then just start punching the fuck out of oak
check.
That's why you're talking about pod.
It drive by beating.
He just started wailing on him and he's like,
fuck you.
You don't know.
You don't really frosted.
My cake in this whole exchange was,
I remember he was saying,
you've got nothing to worry about.
This is like a Dave Matthews concert and then he gets punched
Jimmy Walker and Ron Jeremy.
That's Joel.
And um,
no,
but like the idea that like,
I'll talk to bobcat and the language,
you can understand,
it's like a Dave Matthews concert.
I'm like,
I wouldn't go see Dave Matthews.
I think he's trying to say it's six chill.
Yeah.
Dave Matthews conscious.
You know what I gotta say this crowd,
they were really nice,
but then a object got hit in the hand with a guy hit in the head with a can of
Phaco and it and he kind of slumped over the steering wheel unconscious and he's
like steer
steering with a semi conscious clone.
God can get you to repeat the,
I don't think I remember that game show story from Australia,
but I can't remember that story.
But
adding this woman's Buzzer,
I was on a game show,
Sophie,
that was her day
hitting my budget.
I go,
Hey lady,
if you're going to lose,
just lose.
Don't drag me into this.
Oh Man.
Wow,
that's great for a Friday.
Nigeria.
Unfortunately it's Thursday,
right?
This,
I love that.
You don't know what day?
Thursday,
Thursday.
I never know.
Unless I have gigs.
I have two gates tonight.
And you got to,
we'd be wrapping this up.
Yeah,
I got one at the w and I got one of the comedy store.
But,
um,
there were a ton of fun at the comedy store.
10 45.
Okay.
Yeah.
Can you get me in man?
Yeah,
Bro.
Don't worry about it.
Come on down.
Keep drinking.
No.
You know what,
this is the end of the tour and downs.
I've been,
I,
this is like the hundredth interview in 10 days or something and it's like,
I can only mention about your rate,
bury those.
That's unfortunate.
You have to do press for these things,
but it's kind of throwing around weights important.
Thrilled.
And I'm so again,
I how much,
I mean,
we just named the movie the right thing because just to look at what this
fucking guy has done for me and he's had to,
and he's also had a sort of,
and I,
there's times when I've milked the fact that the,
I'm watching him treatment with kid gloves and I'm going like,
Hey,
you know what I mean?
Let this go on.
So August 7th is a,
it's going to be rolls out this Friday and that'll be,
that'll be like,
oh,
it'll be across the country.
No,
no.
It'll be in New York.
Uh,
probably show you if you keep scrolling.
New York,
DC,
Austin,
um,
here in La Santa and I have seen New York,
Washington,
Angelica,
Papa Vegas.
Okay.
So it's all call me lucky movie.com.
It's all available on the,
on the website,
but it's your show.
I'm bitchy ass shit.
You,
yeah,
I shading that we dropped parties and upstate New York.
I should understanding that it's going to be available up there to look at that
stitches.
Powerful stitches.
Oh yeah.
That's where I did my first open mind.
Who hosted?
Um,
Jonathan Katz.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
that was pretty cool.
John.
Love that guy.
He's in the movie.
Yep.
Yes,
he is.
Um,
when's it going to be available?
Like an iTunes and all that stuff will become like,
it'll be on Netflix,
I think Netflix.
Yeah.
You know,
most of my,
I actually all my movies end up on digital platforms,
so I'm unlike those movies though.
MPI The folks putting it out,
you know,
believe in giving this one a little bit broader of a theatrical run.
Nice.
Yeah,
that's great.
Yeah.
Willow Creek road as good,
whatever happened with that.
Uh,
do well,
did well for me.
It actually helped,
um,
the same company that put that out said when I said,
hey,
I want to make a movie about this guy and it's about his child abuse.
They were going fine.
It was really cool.
Wow.
So Robin and given us the money to start the beginning of it and then an NPI
didn't,
they were cool man.
They weren't really,
they,
they're very supportive of what I do.
That's awesome.
Barry Crimmins has been an honor.
Thank you sir.
Thanks for being here.
Thanks for bothering you.
You unbelievable.
I've been so honored to be on your show,
Bob.
First interview,
I got hammered in and out of a hundred
guys fucking apologize.
But I was going to do with somewhere.
I thought I was gonna say Bob,
miss it.
I've done it.
No more movies.
No amyl
hammered and hammered,
but they're a little bit,
I love you man.
Thanks.
Fucking greatest.
What?
You're beautiful.
But I mean,
honestly,
how much more I like fucking,
you know,
act of friendship is one thing.
A documentary of it is quite another.
Thank you very much.
I'd love my brother and I'm most appreciative and thank you so much for having
me on Joe,
and I hope I get to come back and hang out.
Right.
See what we fucking skip off on.
Absolutely.
Anytime I'm come on back.
So proud to know you,
my honor.
Thank you very much.
All right,
everybody.
We'll be back.
Uh,
what's today?
Thursday.
Wednesday,
We'd be back tomorrow.
All right.
Love you guys.
Bye.
Yeah.